this video is sponsored by liquid IV
more on them after the reaction
people citizens of the reject Nation it
is I Andrew Flash Gordon and this is my
first time hosting ever on a YouTube
channel I'm so nervous and scared I
don't know how this goes but I am joined
by my co-host eron hello it is
me Mario and we are here to do a film
called love Simon I've never heard of
this movie I do not know what to expect
have you ever heard of this film I have
heard of this film I don't know much
about it okay good to know well let us
know in the comments section what do you
guys think of this film what are you
expecting on this reaction that's what I
want to know if you don't mind leave us
a like do all the YouTube things you
guys do we appreciate it and also want
to give uh thanks to prepper for editing
down all these highlights with uh you
got all my superhero references and
everything it takes hours at a time so
special thanks to
them wow is this your first time on a
YouTube it is also full length Reaction
watch along where you sync up with your
own copy where you join us on patreon
it's where we call you super sexy you
get to watch the whole thing with Aaron
and myself and also you get to watch
John and Greg do a bunch of exclusive
other shows and with that we are ready
to watch Love
Simon I'm just like you for the most
part my life is totally normal my dad
was the annoyingly handsome quarterback
who married the hot valedictorian and no
they didn't peek in I school I have a
sister I actually like not that I'd ever
tell her that last year in 200 episodes
of chop too she decided she wanted to be
a chef good choice which means we're
pretty much all her test subjects now
sence of the food's good it's
[Music]
okay and then there's my friends two of
them I've known since pretty much the
beginning of time or at least
kindergarten hey is that the kid in uh
Spider-Man homecoming the one with Betty
brand this year has been nothing short
of it is crazy it's like insane Jason
what no swearing he totally is I just
storm yeah drink way too much ice coffee
and the girl from 13 Reasons Why
dreaming of college and gorging on
[Music]
cars that's something I would totally do
counting down the days I'm just like you
I have a totally perfectly normal life
except I have one huge ass
[Music]
secret he likes gardening nothing wrong
with that morning oh sorry I didn't
realize you were your sister's
downstairs making some L do pancake then
should probably go eat that great I'll
be down in just a second right after
you're finished searching the internet
for lingerie photos of XII H uh peer
pressure all right finish up
here you got me it's look enough
gardening tools sir
father it's like what's going to be more
scary me having to tell my parents about
you know my sexual preference or me
battling T-Rexes and
velociraptors if you seen Jurassic world
you know what I'm talking about Aaron
listen I don't think dinosaurs Trump
parental rejection that's true okay
these are incredible cornal pancakes
with Blackberry compound damn those look
bomb those don't look fire low key see
you guys honey be back lie it's nice
having a sister for a chef mine's a
dietitian but she's a damn good cook
mine plays soccer Mine played soccer
Mine played soccer too hey morning it's
Simon I live I live right
here I like your your
boots
goodbye good conversation nailing you're
you're getting somewhere with him next
time you can ask him what his favorite
color
[Music]
is oh that's cool the craziest dream
last night Nick you had the craziest
dream Alexandria ship what's her name
yeah David Beckham is there with these
two contact lenses and like blue one and
red one like he's like a sexy he had a
dream about a soccer player Color Me
shocked have you guys seen Creek Secrets
today apparently Becca Peterson got
caught given Ryan o Donovan and HJ in
the pool that's the real reason they
drained it what's an HJ say it out loud
for those of us who don't know say out
loud for the people in the back hi can
we get four I coffees please I can tell
this soundtrack is going to be fire oh
yeah it's giving teenage
angst already already got a lot of comic
book actors and actresses in this yeah
you got Electra you got him from
Spider-Man you got storm yeah sorry guys
I can't help it I see comic book actors
I'm going to mention it you
know maybe it's something that you're
not seeing clearly like something that's
like right in front of your face what am
I not seeing no idea dang he must feel
really lonely having to hide that secret
from everybody yeah like while he does
have friends he's still and he's not
yeah he's afraid he does I mean can't be
honest it's it's understandable cuz you
don't know how PE some people are going
to react but if they're really your
friends they'll accept you otherwise
they're not your friends right true
still that fear though of course no no
no totally understand you don't want to
lose
them it's an interesting you know Gap
pose like do I want to just hold in the
secret and keep my friends or risk
telling them and losing them mhm great
choice on the cargo pants by the way it
looks like you got ganged by a TJ Max
whatever oh that's not cool wish Ethan
wouldn't make it so easy for them that
was a funny disc though the TJ Maxx line
come on phone off there's a whole world
to look at you can look people in the
eyes stop for the Selfies you're not all
that this is all that that was a good
show I understood that reference it was
a great show oh I see more
phones this guy clearly is a high school
teacher to to still be in high
school I can't believe we have to be
Greg berlan CW directed it oh wow CW
verse you excited to rehearse with you
later do you know that Cabaret was
actually based off a play called I am
camera and I am camera was based off
this novel called uh goodbye to Berlin
and that's great that's that's wonderful
I think she found that interesting bye
Martin well being a someone who comes up
with so many non-relevant uh references
I'm the king of what he's
saying we cannot watch the affair as a
family why not because it's all about SX
they should watch Unfaithful it's a good
one I don't think I've heard of that one
oh really that's a good one okay you
know what we didn't see last week's
episode of The Bachelor how did that guy
even become the bachelor it's a good
family show well he's clearly gay The
Bachelor oh Dad so oh
no I wonder why he's afraid to tell his
dad um yeah after this i g show you one
okay yeah yeah this highlights w you
know poor guy man yeah he's a man's his
dad's a man's man I mean he doesn't even
understand how disrespectful he's
being
sucks a that's
cute look at this wait wait
wait this is your 20th anniversary so
I'm going to be super real with you
right now this looks like a fourth
grader made
it like a deeply averaged fourth grader
deeply averaged fourth grader
it's like I worked on this for 30
minutes how dare you say this to me we
just got to put in you know some home
video putting some better music this was
huge When We Were Young yeah yeah so was
Bill
Cosby he has a
point have you seen the new post I'm
never getting back in that pool again wa
no about the CL a gay kid at
school what yeah it's on Creek secret
what of the come out when does it take
place you mean what year yeah I think I
saw 2018 I think
okay who do you think it is maybe it's
Parker or I heard like obsessed with
it's me Simon sometimes I feel like I'm
stuck on a ferris wheel 1 minute I'm on
top of the world and the next I'm at
rock bottom over and over all day long
because a lot of my life is great but
nobody knows I'm gay blue Anonymous man
I get
it he's wearing a blue sweater ah good
good
[Music]
catch from my window one I see what you
guys did there see what you did Greg
bante you're not you're not
clever this guy is so endearing I love
this guy yeah no he's a very he's a very
kind and I mean so far of what we've
seen of him he's a very kind and nice
Soul de blue I'm just like for the most
part my life is totally normal the
annoyingly handsome quarterback who
married the hot Val PE in high school I
have a sister I actually like this is
almost like the narration from the
beginning narration he was talking in
blue ah except I have one huge ass
secret oh
yeah I like gardening isn't that what
you said yeah
exactly you can say it but I mean it's
Anonymous at this say I love my
hose
you can't say it not even in text I
understand the idea of being judged it
sucks it's a real thing the idea of not
being accepted
yeah nothing can anyone answer for me
how we find the value of Dy by DX what's
the answer Aaron Degeneration X there
you go Simon Simon hey w-e West Greg
brante another superhero character
I just found a press on nail in my salad
eat it it's good for you it's protein
ew can't text in the Halls how many
times have I told you that I can't have
all my students tendering it up that's
my department what I got a really hot
day tonight why are you telling him this
Vice principles can't go on dates that's
gross we're people too Simon is he being
honest I think he is but he's a s lack
of boundary with his students yeah could
I just get my phone unfortunately I'm
going to have to keep it until after
practice but you will get your precious
after that's dumb my precious my
precious I went to school at a time
where cell phones were not as prevalent
as now I don't is that an actual rule no
in the hallway I don't no that seems
like it's
[__] in class I get but yeah like
and he can't be the only one using his
phone all right that was Cal help me
that was that was a start that was a
start Miss Albright that was the biggest
train wreck our stage has ever seen and
Rob and Brienne were practically brutal
honesty it'll take you far in life yeah
save the kissing all right This Is War
you're
Nazis more anger boo I was an extra in
The Lion King and this is where I
am come on Aaron little impressed by
that I was impressed it's my Han Zimmer
impression where's my precious uh just
here for my phone oh of course you are
he's got like truckloads of
phones you can call me AT&T Simon I know
that I'm hard on you I really do you
shouldn't say that it's only cuz I
really see myself in
you very poor choice of
words is there something you want to say
to me you know my policy what does it
say open door policy U there's nothing
you want to say nope did he did he go
through his phone it's feeling like he
went through his phone don't text and
drive that's time my cat got murdered
I'm just kidding I don't have cats I got
asthma he's an interesting administrator
that's the reason I can't breathe cuz my
asthma not my
allergies did he message you he did
secret huh is it the same as my secret
if it is who is it I'm so curious do you
think it's someone we've already met
maybe it's the gardener really probably
not I feel like it's someone who go
obviously someone who goes would be
random if it was the gardener The
Gardener goes to the school he just
doesn't know it yet it's got to be
someone we've met right probably at this
point and honestly I can't even really
explain why deep down I know my family
would be fine with it at the end of the
day it doesn't really matter who it is I
his patri
though patri when Ethan came out no one
even cared guys I have something to tell
you I'm gay wow
really damn that's crazy what a complete
surprise too much
CL
like this one recurring dream I kept
having about Daniel Radcliff I'm a
wizard I was obsessed with panic at The
Discord he's so cute he's so cute
he's then I realized it really wasn't
about the music well yeah he's okay it
was my first girlfriend I think in love
with you damn thank you be right back
damn that's crazy girl that's crazy too
when you're like not putting in any kind
of effort and a girl says I love you
like that it's like damn how about you
how did you know warmly
Jack this is this is sweet though CU he
can't he feels like he can't talk to
anyone so yeah now he has someone to
talk to about this stuff anonymously
your proudest moment happened in middle
school that would be pretty sad for me I
realized I like guys watching Game of
Thrones my friends were all holding
their breath almost did look like the
gardener I was crushing hard on Jon Snow
Well I've never told anyone about my
Daniel Radcliff phase so now we're even
if I want to find you at school I just
have to look for for the Game of Thrones
fanatic it's a popular character
especially at this time when it's on the
air yeah obviously some of the things
I've told you about myself are things
I've never talked about with anyone
something about you that makes me want
to open up and that's slightly
terrifying you think he's going to
deduce the wrong person he might
Halloween's all about the Oreos with the
orange frosting in the middle oh yeah
the orange frosting in Halloween INF
factual you going you look happy I'm a
little why why way I've been 10 or dat
last night bro like I'm not the guy I'm
not the one to tell this to he really
likes to share information with students
about his personal life where are your
friends bro I don't know if he has
that he's not he's a nice guy but uh for
Cabaret yeah take care of his bread I
wouldn't be surprised if it's him he's
been talking to oh okay okay putting it
in the rediction Hat your
[Music]
whbs H or not r
or maybe it's not him I don't think it
is not at this point Oreos man I love
this Halloween one's for the best oh I
think it's him I think showing the I
think showing the guy is a mislead my
mom is going down to Orlando to deal
with it which means I get to throw a
Halloween party
awesome it could be him but also Oreos
are a very popular thing so I'm not
saying it's not him I'm just making an
observation Oreos are extremely popular
nope only one person likes Oreos Andrew
only one you assume so much risk when
you throw a party in my opinion see
someone with orange Oreos Go full in
agreement on Oreos told
you I said I didn't say it wasn't him I
just said I would I'm just saying it was
it's a very popular item I can't stop
thinking about kissing
you Simon Simon oh but that was in his
head so was not confirmed oh damn okay
told you no I'm just kid
I thought I was so right for a second it
could it it definitely could be him he's
a he's a candidate but my hair's kind of
like my thing I'm going to go get a soda
um you want anything oh gave him the
look oh he discovered whose email it was
he knows a secret hey um I used the uh
computer in the library right after
you well I went to Gmail and it pulled
up your account and I uh read some of
your emails D why you doing it bro mind
your own business you knowsy ass so you
be interested to know my brother's gay M
that wouldn't interest me to know okay
don't worry I won't show anyone I don't
like this did you print my emails or
something no no no no why are you
blackmailing him I screenshot them
screenshotted my emails why would you do
that why would you why would you do that
is so intrusive and Despicable why the
hell did you screenshot my emails well
you and Abby sua are good friends what
does that have to do with anything well
I need you do help me hook up with her
and hang out with her and stuff you're
slimy he is so creepy this dude are you
blackmailing me sh I knew it I freaking
knew it you can help me yeah what if I
say no dude Jesus couldn't help you then
the whole world will know you're gay and
reject you forever I I just think that
we're in a position here where we can
help each other out as home you're slimy
you're trash Brock you're trash Brock do
you understand that reference I'll give
you there it is it's Brock sir Edward
Brock
Jr it's asking me if I understood a
superhero reference I would have shocked
if you didn't get that
me the other day you asked me what I was
wearing for Halloween and I said I
wasn't dressing all right we're hearing
his voice actor plays W West truth is I
didn't want you to know what I was
wearing because I don't want you to know
who I am maybe I was right I it it
probably is him it is him I'm just not
ready for my whole world to change I
hope you understand yes blue I
understand man I feel for him this is so
this is such a tough situation
especially when you hear everyone like
how everyone's chattering and talking
about it too people were just more in an
accepting like talk about it it's like
okay if you want me to help you with
Abby you cannot eat that so you're going
to help yeah and you got to delete those
pictures but also the problem is he's
got word of mouth too he can
mhm all right here we
go and here we
go this is where the magic happens that
is not a place to bring women I've been
dabbling in closeup illusions I think he
likes magic I don't know why I would say
that but I think just a guess I'm just
going to take a guess just little little
small one if you want Abby to like you
what you have to do is you have to make
my name boret very nice you like dudes
tell me what part of me do you find the
hottest come on bro chill they don't
want to read your clothes I don't want
your help in changing me I want your
help in getting happy to like me for me
okay so we got to change you
just you're an you're repulsive we need
to change everything about you
do you want to go with my friends and I
yes so simple must be why they call you
Simple Simon nobody calls me that Martin
that's
insulting this is my favorite time of
the year cuz it kicks off the three best
holidays Aaron shocking this is like a
new level of laziness even that's a
great wig what the hell you didn't get
that at a Halloween store hey don't talk
about Yoko that way man cuz if you do
yeah out of the band Yoko Ono John
Lennon and Yoko Ono see I knew one she
can't be Yoko
what a woman in his she should have
dressed like storm to meta two on the
nose just meta enough she was putting
that into the universe that she wants to
be a superhero I uh I'm going to go make
those for some pizzas wait no wouldn't
she already filmed that at this point uh
this is 2018 so she did X-Men apocalypse
in 2016 so yes oh okay okay remember
when we went to school dressed as
Charlie's Angels oh my God yes and
Nick's balls fell out of his booty
shorts when he
like no the balls out the booty shorts
that's an image I will not get out of my
head now that's a hilarious statement
who's
that I invited Martin Martin Addison why
is this a make a wish situation wow
Aaron and I are
displeased oh he said they don't want to
read your
clothes what are you supposed to be I am
a Freudian slip oh Jesus hey here's an
interesting question I love Beyonce
whates you guys feel nostalgic y'all are
on the different wavelengths bro makes
me feel very
nostalgic I'm cringing I'm cringing so
hard I think Abby is into him why is
Nick still fighting with Abby I don't
know Martin maybe you shouldn't have
worn a
dress hey John
Lennon he got it I thought he was going
to dress up as an orange
Oreo oh uh I am post presidency Barack
Obama just
chilling nice we could all dream of that
you need to let it go need to let it
go when I get drunken off or have a
little liquid courage then I I get up on
the karaoke stage hey I want to see that
happen you've you've seen it at Greg's
birthdays I didn't I didn't go to the
last birthday party I wasn't here this
past year ah you missed out I was there
two years ago ah Abby is the hottest
wonder woman I've ever seen yeah [__]
that I will let do to me with that lasso
oh I know man she'd make you tell the
truth you're not in it Abby are you no
she's cute but she's not really my
type not because she's
black oh God stop it just don't do that
don't do
that you don't have to it's okay put put
his foot in his mouth on that one oh
[Music]
God I'm
I'm cringing internally you can't ask
Abby out why not because she didn't tell
you about
Jonathan you're ruining your friendships
in college uh-huh he's really
experienced oh because he hasn't been
honest that's why he's not being honest
about they like each other he's trying
to ruin their connection for
self-preservation and then that's going
to come out and there's going to be a
whole Fallout and then him being gay is
going to come out and they're like oh we
accept you and love you exactly hey
Simon hey hey you want to play uh b r
yeah oooop o how about you and me and
then um Abby and Marton no no I
don't oh lord it's like why what have I
done to deserve this my God you guys
just ear in the same Vibe bro and that's
okay you got to find someone who is unto
your
Vibe see better right good idea all you
rain drop all right drop top
I have a feeling he's going to get so
drunk that he's going to let it out
Martin that's interesting
[Music]
Theory hey Ram it's me
jacqu I'm Jo h i mean you can be on you
can say that and if it weren't him he
would be like who the hell is YC mhm
like you'd still be protected from your
secret he's going to walk on him making
out with somebody then he's going to go
yep yep go oh as they do as the movies
do I'm I'm sorry I thought this was the
bathroom a poor guy though I guess it's
not him still could be he's just keeping
up appearances could be maybe as comes
to turn with it not going to lie that
girl he was hooking up with was uh
pretty attractive and in real life she's
not in high
school mother trucker you're you're oh
you're fun you're awesome you must be
fun at
parties that's don't ridicule me in the
comments she's not really in high school
in real life she's probably like 24
25 got to cover your bases
yeah I bet she likes him and then he's
going to come out to her first I would
not be surprised by that look we're so
close oh my God I thought for a moment
too she might be a little interested in
Martin but like he is so as you say
repulsive like I don't know how anybody
could like that guy he's got to get a
lot more mature just is just you know
needs some more
self-awareness hey guys hey come talk to
look at this cute couple
Aces uh well thanks
for you at least clean the shoes up my
guy do you ever feel weird all the time
sometimes I feel like I'm always on the
outside snaps snaps to that I was at
that party and it was fun but kind of
felt like I was watching it from across
the
room I don't know like there's this
invisible line that I have to cross to
really be a part of everything and I
just I can't ever cross it feel that way
sometimes too I feel you yeah sometimes
I think it'd be so much easier to be one
of these people who can just take a few
shots and then hook up with whoever's
closest it's the best way to go to a
party I'm not a casual person what kind
of person are
you I think I'm the kind of person who
is destined to care so much about one
person it nearly kills
me me too
uhoh H uhoh oh she's having a moment
he's not
R
uh I just feel bad for her cuz she
doesn't know why he didn't yeah shair
hit the same same sentiment and I guess
we all have secrets I've been thinking
about why I haven't come out yet maybe
it's because it doesn't seem fair that
only gay people have to come out why is
straight the default mom there's
something I have to tell you I'm
straight I'm
straight I like
girls you get that from your daddy side
you get that from your daddy side can't
be sure this whole being gay thing is
forever maybe it's that there's not that
much of high school left and part of me
wants to hold on to who I've always been
when I go to college in Los Angeles I'll
be gay and proud I
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
promise
somebody yeah maybe not that
gay I'll keep ruminating love
jacqu what what what happened you but
love he like oh no it's going to reject
me cuz I put love oh thought it was like
linked to a certain account or something
that reveal red no cuz remember he'd
always edit it to like make it more
casual yeah anybody else Christmas in
the Caribbean I'm going to an unheated
vacation house in the middle of nowhere
as is our leak family
tradition paper cut those hurt do you
know where the bandages are yeah why
don't you show me do you mind showing me
it's not working I don't actually have a
paper cut I know that Martin you're a
very bad actor you cannot bring blue
into this okay if he found out that
mimos got leaked he'd get totally
freaked why he never talked me that
rhymed internet's a freaky place to meet
people Freaky Friday fre fun movie
Friday that's a fun
movie you know Martin was having trouble
running his lines and we were thinking
we could go to Waffle House and go over
him Waffle House where do this take
place on the East Coast I would assume
so we ain't got that in California plus
he said he was going to go to what do we
have here rosos we do have
rosos you said love if I were a betting
man say you were drunk emailing me
during that last yeah see it's not his
Wally West voice anymore as for coming
out I know what you mean about wanting
to wait till college but our emails have
inspired me I'm going to tell my family
so thanks shck it really could be that
Gardener guy I don't know it's not
really the point of who it who it is but
just curiosity I hope it's somebody
we're definitely going to get to see
them by the end of this I'm sure we will
but again I feel like it was a mislead I
still feel like it's that dude you mean
Wally West Wally West the thespians
rehearse hey guys what can I get you or
it's him oh it could be him we have a
Latin together I don't think so it's ly
actually we had uh bio together last
year oh really Simon right yeah sorry I
don't um it's okay it was like a big
class and I have a good memory for faces
okay there we go oh there's a Vibe and
much too distracting and you never did
any acting at your old school no
flattery will get you so far can you
give me my next queue though so why why
did you move here oh Jesus listen bro
you need to listen because my parents
got divorced oh why they get divorced
Martin are you writing a book about
girls from a broken home in
DC got got to chill I thought that my
dad was the greatest person on the
planet but it turns out that he's just a
sad tired loser who hates his job drinks
way too much beer and cheats on his wife
I'm sorry to hear that you deserve the
father that you thought you had oh my go
tenderness actually don't ruin it don't
it up I want to hear you say I AB you to
so and an an incredible young woman and
deserve a goddamn superhero I'm not
going to say that Martin well um I won't
stop until you say
it I'm cringing Abby here I hate this is
an incredible young woman please you're
embarrassing her bro that's right
Abby is an incredible young woman
incredible young woman and deserves a
godamn superhero oh this
working a godamn superhero this is
working wow I'm shook only in the movie
this would work only in a freaking movie
dude no way breakthrough yeah all right
give me my waffles now please please sit
down that was a cute moment though
actually as much as I don't like Martin
that wasn't a sweet moment well uh let's
get back uh uhoh is she developing some
feelings possibly now could be could be
could be I'll be right back oh you can
see oh she is wow I'm surprised I'm
shooketh were you in BIO when they did
that identifying leaves test and uh Joel
wissow at that poison ivy because Doug
fogy told him it was pot you see
everything don't you Simon Simon means
the one who hears spear means the one
who sees you put that all together I've
got to get back inside and scrub down
some waffle irons I'll see you in there
yeah I'll see
you he just got an email he's not blue
wait was he though doing stuff on the
phone right before he sent that or so my
dad lying in tonight for Hanukkah if you
are thinking but he's just thinking it's
him welcome to navigating divorce
parents take holiday where you can get
them and my dad staying at the same
crappy Motel as always we'll do all our
horribly awkward tradition H do you
think I'm crazy I think you're crazy
Brave again that doesn't confirm it him
it's just what he believes and since
yeah yep okay we're back at square zero
honestly Martin used to annoy the crap
out of me but he's actually kind of a
cool person do you I've been mean to ask
you about your parents no I I don't
mention it a lot because it kind of M
with my image girl who is excited to
start a new school senior year M girl
whose life didn't just end like 3 months
ago who's angry and sad all the time see
it's not just sexual preference things
we keep within don't want to share you
still believe in love maybe have you
ever been in love I think so is he going
to tell her maybe he's going to tell her
he's going to say
gay oh it's cool first person he told
nobody really knows and I don't don't
really want people to find out I W I
promise a that's so
sweet respecting boundaries you
surprised
no so you knew no but you're not
surprised do you want me to be surprised
I don't know okay well I love you
a love you too when he said are you
surprised he said no that was such a
good delivery mhm there's no one behind
us you don't have to put your being safe
that's such a big step for him he told
somebody that's awwesome but also
hearing that someone in his friend
Circle accepted it someone close to him
like I think that was also a big
Revelation and stepping stone for him as
well that'll probably Inspire him to
tell other people you inspired me I came
out to my friend tonight I never would
have done that without you maybe we
should ride this bravery train and
reveal our identities I'm dying to know
who you are a take those steps man you
take those steps that's awesome I told
my dad who's insanely awkward but it's
you who inspires me but I'm sorry I'm
just not ready for us to know each
other's
identities damn but why I'm a fry shark
yeah and my name is Bruce shocking
you're a good fry Shar thank you thank
you I like that I didn't uh I feel bad
for him yeah Simon since when does Abby
find Martin so goddamn
funny I'm just going to tell her that I
like her and I've been thinking the
whole sexual experience thing it's not
that big of a deal actually I've been
practicing right I got this thing online
it's really it's called a pocket likes
Martin no I hate this look I I don't
care I'm just I'm going to try wait wait
what about Leah what about Leah oh don't
do this don't be a bad friend Leah's in
love with you no she's not why are you
setting him up for rejection what are
you doing I hate this this is awful she
blushes every time you come into the
room in factual you and Abby never going
to happen you and Leah
oh you could be in together you're being
a bad friend so I have something to tell
you I like you Nick just asked me to get
dinner before the homecoming game he
came up to me and he's like do you want
to go get dinner right and I was like
sure ab and Simon and and he was like I
was thinking it could just be the two of
us like a date that's amazing I know
you're into
it all that stuff you were talking about
the night after bram's party it was
about you it's about you fool you cannot
be that naive my friend so you think I
should go out with him yes yeah yeah I
promise you you're not going to regret
it it's going to be great
[Music]
oh I assume you can't text at football
games either right no the principal's on
it he's going to take your phone there
too wont QB is insanely hot we can talk
about stuff like this now you know yeah
I uh still haven't really quite figured
out
how Simo do you think that that
quarterback is looking
fine it's looking pretty
fine
f f
oh hey TR it's the Waffle House guy
Lyall ly uh I don't know could be I
don't know do you think he's I don't
know okay well you should talk to him
I'm going to go get a coffee oh so she
knows about the emails then right it
sounds like no she just knows that she
oh oh she was asking do you think he
could be okay I thought she was asking
do you think he could be the email Guy
no that's why I thought she was
inferring I'm glad you're here you are
yeah cuz I wanted to ask you something I
was going to ask you the other day are
you shc he's going to ask her about the
friend what's Abby's deal told you I
told
you I I know I called it like 4 seconds
before he said it
but poor
guy uh I got to go I see you dude you
got to stop predicting and thinking who
you little birdie told me you're in the
May is that Mar is that Martin met him
yeah totally I figured out my next move
with the app great that's good for you
Martin I just wanted to run it by you
real quick I've been helping you for
weeks and I am sick and tired of helping
you mess with my friends's lives so why
don't you just do that [__] that you did
at Waffle House that went great so so
you're saying I should go for
it that was dinner it was good yeah she
wasn't into it that dumpling place I
told you about oh you know maybe you
could go with
Martin messing with your
friends please stand for the national
anthem oh
can oh my God no no please God please
God don't do this I had a feeling he was
going to do this oh I I don't want to
watch I don't want to I don't want to be
here for
this no God why everyone sorry to
interrupt interrup and I don't know if I
can watch this dude I don't know I don't
know if my cringe can take it Abigail
cine
Su just a short 3 and 1 half months ago
you not only transferred into a new new
school you transferred your way into a
new heart belonging to me are you not
yeah you're uncomfortable too okay cool
the
135,00 minutes that we've spent together
135,000
31 I don't know what to do with my body
I smart talented oh no I mean it takes a
lot of Courage like not but yeah it's
embarrassing no well like used to say
y'all are filming it this man's ruining
his high school career will you go out
with me no God no this is cringe this is
so freaking cringe I am so
sorry I don't feel that way about you o
we could still be friends you know are
those doves oh
no oh sheesh hey no no she said no no
don't okay okay the cringe has passed
nice try Martin and way to go Martin you
gave it a shot
right yeah I I spoke prematurely the
cringe is it still lives here it's taken
residence that was terrible don't worry
people will get over it in a few
weeks oh the memes that would so go oh
he's definitely going to out you now
that would so go viral
100% I mean everything goes viral
nowadays these are some outdated memes
even for this this time but the
sentiment is there Martin it's Simon
want to make sure you're doing all right
I know it's been tough since uh well you
know since when since you're publicly
humiliated yourself went viral I just
want to make sure you're okay okay hey
it scared the crap out of me I'm
drinking eggnog and packing to go to my
dad's cabin on Lake Raven pretty sure
there's a photo of it on the wikkipedia
page for middle of nowhere I'm going to
an unheated vacation house in the middle
of nowhere dude stop guessing who it is
you did say that it might have been him
earlier right did I I I think you did
I'm pretty sure you You' said it was
like I've called everyone but him sounds
like you're going to need some good
music so I'm sending a list of the seven
best Christmas songs of all I love
Christmas songs Smokey Robinson and the
Miracles Christmas every day but the
number one song you're going to need
don't say Mariah
[Music]
Carey Jackson
5 S hey have you seen it uhoh he outed
you Creek Secret
so he screenshotted it that is not cool
dude he tried his best Simon spear has a
secret male pen pal because he's gay
dude really he tried helping you that's
not his fault right talking about this
instead of Martin Addison's homecoming
debacle which was actually kind of sweet
trying to take the heat off of himself I
never thought I could hate this
character even more than I do right now
but no that guy sucked from the
beginning well at the D at the waffle
place I'm like oh okay there's a little
that was still cringe I was surprised
that she was into that hi no the oh the
sister knows
too I'm
gay
oh oh like what are you going to do I
don't know you could deny it why the
hell would I deny it nor I'm I'm I'm not
ashamed of it what the hell are you
talking about
sorry and someone posted our emails
please don't freak out I need you to
promise me you won't
disappear
want to go for a walk yeah he just
doesn't just like get away from
technology right
now I'm not a violent person and I do
not condone violence in any way but
Martin deserves a nice
beating that guy was is trash did and
has been trash from the start of this
movie this one Sherlock there you
go Bluetooth headphones do you like the
black you actually um I did want to talk
to you guys about about something right
now well let me guess you got somebody
pregnant knew it I'm I knew it he's got
that glob on him babe dude let him talk
dude stop with the
jokes I'm gay honey oh the two parents
different reactions man I'm still me of
course you are yeah Simon oh the dad so
you're gay which one of your old
girlfriends turned you was it the uh the
one with the big eyebrow or the one with
the BRAC can you ever shut the hell up
I'm kidding it's not funny yeah it's not
funny dude
please yeah you're being so insensitive
that is not a react he's trying to yeah
no I deflect or diffuse with humor I
came out to my entire family on
Christmas it didn't go great and I've
been avoiding my friends the whole break
for all sorts of reasons change is
exhausting I feel like there's nowhere
to hide from all the newness of
everything except here with you I mean
I'm happy he's able to to be open and
free you know but sucks how it
happened come sit down going to be late
oh boy this is going to be a tough first
day for him I feel he's
isolating hey guys hey Simon We you to
talk oh about what he did now we're
together that's awesome they're mad at
you though then we got to talking about
why it took so
long Martin was the one who wrote that
Creek Secrets post about me he told me
that if I didn't help him get with Abby
he'd out me that's why I had to keep you
guys apart so you made up a bunch of
lies I'm not a piece of meat Simon you
know how hard it was for me to start
over I trusted
you I know I messed up okay but I I knew
you were in love with Nick and I thought
that maybe just stop it no no no no no
no you're insanely stupid Simon I was
never in love with Nick I was in love
with
you I can deal with you being gay sigh
but you set me up to get my heartbroken
when you thought I was in love with Nick
and that just makes you
cruel he was scared self reservation uh
for the uh for the record when I was
saying that we have a lot in common you
know I wasn't really oh shut up did you
J me because you think I look like a guy
oh no broke up with you because you
don't look like a
guy that makes
sense
hey oh that is the guy from Cobra Kai
yeah hit him I'll take it from here hey
Miss Au don't hate Miss All Bright me
we're not friends you're not going to
break and this is complete harassment
you know what you're about to be
suspended for so long that by the time
it's over you're going to be the fat
bald Unhappily Married wildly mediocre
nobodies you're destined to be damn you
can't talk to us like that actually I
can and you know why because you're just
those two [__] that did that shitty
thing in front of the whole school
nobody feels sorry for those [__]
especially me go you go mik Dro you
might have just got fired but you go
why does Mr worth have to talk to us
can't we just let this [__] go he wasn't
even part of this why why is he there
hey I'm sorry Ethan none of this ever
happened when just you were out you know
what they say one gay is a snooze two is
a hilarious hate crime you could have
told me you were gay I guess I didn't
think we had very much in common you're
telling me Simon it's not like your all
hoodie wardrobe rocks my world you've
been out since you were 16 and always
seems so easy for you easy my mom still
tells my grandparents about all the
girls I'm dating when we go over to
their house for dinner jeez dang she
says it's cuz they're old and religious
it's just easier that
way okay these gentlemen have something
that they would like to say to you I am
pieces of we are pieces of craps we are
boo boo incarnate we respect Simon and
Ethan's choice to be boyfriends we are
not boyfriends whatever whatever you
want to call us fine with me seriously
we this guy has no filter he's the worst
oh Simon hit him hit him hit
him I just wanted to say that I was
sorry okay I I no you're not I got a lot
of [__] for homecoming and I wanted
everyone to focus on something else you
know I I just didn't think it was you
have no excuse I'm supposed to be the
one that decides when and where and how
and who knows and how I get to say it
that's supposed to be my thing and you
took that away from me so look can you
please just get the away from me that's
right great you suck great line great
delivery oh oh no I saw the posts I know
who you are Jac I'm sorry Simon I can't
do this
anymore no you can't leave me alone
everything's falling
apart uh BL blocked him or you got rid
of his email one or the other
permanently that means it has to be
someone at his school right
probably that's
awful you never got to know I don't
think it's him hey hey Simon are you
blue no no it's not me
sorry all right now I'm convinced it is
that Gardener guy from the beginning
maybe we don't get to find out who blue
is yeah at the end of the day it's I
mean but even if we don't find out I
feel like that that guy who we thought
it could have been could be into Simon
did you know I knew you had a secret
when you were little you were so
Carefree but these these the last few
years more and more it's almost like I
could feel you holding your
breath as soon as you came out you said
Mom I'm still me I need you to hear this
you are still you Simon you are still
the same son who I love to
tease and who your father depends on for
just about everything and you're the
same brother who always compliments his
sister on her food
even may you get to to Exhale now Simon
you get to be more you than you have
been in in a very long time you deserve
everything you
want [__] you
movie oh you got
me oh that was so
sweet oh my
God got you too yeah
yeah
all parents were that wonderful right I
fell in love with someone that guy in
the emails I love him and I knew that if
Martin leaked our emails it scare them I
know what I did was messed up my best
friend I'm your best friend then why did
you come out to Abby and not me I think
it was easier known Abby for 6 months
known you for 13 years and I knew that
if I told you that everything was going
to be different understandable tell me
about this guy you love a this is so
sweet oh
so I call him
blue he needs to give his hug his son a
hug and say I love you yeah they need to
have their conversation if that does not
happen I'm going to be very disappointed
how long have you know I was around 13
I'm sorry I shouldn't have missed it no
hey no all the stupid jokes I know you
didn't mean him it doesn't matter I
shouldn't have missed it I just want you
to know that I love
you and I'm really proud of you I
wouldn't change anything about you oh
[__] hey stop
crying come
here that video for Mom coming good good
I need your help on it
though can you help me with that yes
exactly damn yeah damn this movie is
touching it really is
H you never a combo with your sister did
you guys do this I didn't I just help it
was
[Music]
mostly damn they really love each other
I can't believe you did this I panicked
and bought you a watch you can give me
something later that I can't get in the
store that's really gross guys just look
just look at baby be a it's so cute a
recent post on this very website
declared that I was gay the delivery
left something to be desired but the
message is true I am gay for a long time
I was killing myself to hide first I
thought it was just a gay thing but then
I realize no matter what announcing who
you are to the world is pretty
terrifying what if the world doesn't
like you couldn't ask for more Amazing
Friends a more understanding family but
it would all be so much better if I had
someone to share it with so blue do you
think it was that football player that
but I know who you are I know you're
funny and thoughtful you choose your
words carefully and that they're always
perfect a like I told you at the very
beginning I'm just like you so blue
after the play Friday at 10: you know
where I'll be no pressure for you to
show up but I hope you do because you
deserve a great love story too love
Simon Simon I think it's that football
player the one she said it's fine
remember that one it's fine she said
when uh
fine I think it's that one we we haven't
met him though is so maybe it could be
that's my prediction okay I'm going to
go back to my original guess of it being
the dude who held the
party hey Simon hey do you want to go to
the carnival with us tonight
H yes we're the four best friends that
anyone could have and will never ever
ever
where did he say they were going to meet
up at the fountain or I thought I know
he said after the play right yeah I
don't remember what he said though we'll
be right here get
[Music]
him did he say on the ferris wheel or so
that should last a
while oh in the ferris whe okay I bet
he's waiting for the other gay kid
where's Dana she'll love this oh jeez is
subtle with that
[Applause]
comment
so much pressure oh jeez I don't think
he's going to show cuz he put it out
there and now everyone this is his a big
announcement
now I think he will because of what
happened with the email being afraid and
now like hey I he's not I feel like he's
not going to show up for the ferriso but
it'll show up after the fact cuz he's
not ready for the public to see
him okay it's your last ride ticket
buddy wait oh
can I have my ticket Simon it's me no
the it's not no you're not no I'm not I
just this is this is so brutal I here I
tell you what um it's going to say no
way I already knew he wasn't this cap oh
no I can't watch I can't watch this babe
no okay to wait
wait I it I called
it I know I got a little
excited
good job it was Wally West Aaron called
it it's you it's me it's always been me
but that night at the party yeah I was
uh I was drunk and confused and it ended
like a minute after you saw it h I
didn't think you'd come me neither until
I was walking towards you I I didn't
think I had it in
me are you disappointed that it's me
[Music]
no
woo
[Music]
he's been waiting for him hey have you
seen Creek Secrets there are six new
confessions all signed inspired they
hate that I want to be an actor I don't
know if they'll ever be proud of me
Taylor
met you inspired them oh man now we got
to get Leah someone to love I'm enjoying
this movie but I feel like it's had like
it's to end like five
times it's Lord of the Rings Return of
the King it's lord of the freaking Rings
dude I feel like it's keep on the verge
of ending and then keeps going but I'm
that being said I'm enjoying it it just
tonally it feels that
way you buddy got the
crew Everybody in all right it's too
beautiful a day so I think I'm going to
actually take us on a little
Adventure they're having their Ferris
speler Day
Off
damn I want to I feel so dumb what city
are we in I have no
clue I think we've hit the ending I
think so I think I think that's uh a
logical conclusion all right reject
Nation so today I want to share
something with you that has been a
wonderful addition to my health and
fitness journey that I discovered during
the holidays and that is liquid IV's
hydration multiplier I'm down to my very
last packet and I'm freaking out but
it's okay I got more in the mail now a
lot of you have been so kind to notice
how I've been working on my physical
health thank you for all the compliments
and one thing I learned is that proper
hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre-filming
after post-workout and my wife actually
introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good taste and quality
product whether it's after a sweaty
workout or just after you know a good
night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products
that fit that description that also
tastes good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IV hydration multiplier is in
summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers
hydration into your bloodstream faster
and more efficient than water alone
sometimes drinking a whole gallon is not
always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water I'm also
big on efficiency plus it's packed with
11 essential vitamins and we know vins
are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten- free and dairy free you can
customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for postn Recovery
traveling or just having a big night out
you know what I mean no so if you want a
booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid
i.com and use promo code regexs at
checkout that's liquid iv.com promo code
Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
by the way if you guys are listening to
us on Spotify or apple if you don't mind
we would really appreciate it if you
would give us a rating it really does
help us
outon yes what did you think of my
constant interrupting and making you
upset I'm just kid what did you think of
the what did you think of the film I
really liked it I really liked it it had
so much heart it was
funny it was even though I did predict
some things that isn't that's not an
indicator of the quality of how well the
story unfolded I thought it was just so
Charming I Really they really cast and
wrote Simon is such an endearing
character and you understood everything
he was going through and the way he was
feeling and they really put you in his
shoes and it's a story you can connect
to whether you are gay uh whether you
are gay or straight or or anything in
the Spectrum you know I feel like it's
just a very human story about acceptance
cuz like you know we all have things
that we are going through or struggling
through whether it be coming out whether
it be dealing with eating disorders
whether it be you know whatever secret
or or challenge you undergo but the fact
that you see somebody overcome that over
the course of this story and learning to
not well I think he he accepted the fact
that he was gay but worrying about the
perception of how he was going to be
perceived by the people in his life
because he was afraid of change I
thought all of that was very um very
poignant you know and I can connect to
being someone who you know has a
contentious relationship with change so
it was yeah it was great I yeah it's
it's always a good sign when a m movie
can make me laugh make me cry make me
frustrated like it it invoked all of the
emotions over the course of whatever
this runtime was and yeah I've never
seen this movie obviously but I really
really enjoyed it and I'm happy that I
had the experience and I'd recommend it
to other people yeah for sure never seen
it I've never even heard of it before
today but I'm glad uh we got to watch it
it was a beautiful Coming of Age story
and uh I just thought all the
performances were fantastic and i' had
only seen this actor as well in Jurassic
world so I had not really gotten a taste
of his acting range and I just thought
as you said I think the best word to
describe he gave such an endearing
performance and he was an endearing
character as well and I think like you
said too he definitely you know was
accepting of himself but then he was
just worried about you know how other
people were going to you know were going
to perceive him and as well as he was
afraid to scare off you know who uh the
the guy he was emailing which turned out
to be Wally West as we find out later on
in the film so you can understand that
you know we live in a very judgmental
world and uh we even got a little taste
of that with I forgot the other
character uh that we met at the school
that was all gay where he said like yeah
whenever we go to family events my
mother tells my grandp parents who are
very old-fashioned that I have a bunch
of girlfriends and it's like that's a
real that's a real thing that is a real
thing and it's it's you know that's just
the world we live in where some people
just are not accepting the fact and you
know to each their own um I you know I
don't agree with it but it you know
again to each their own but again I just
thought this was a very beautiful film
uh and like you said I I really felt
that it just did a good job of doing a
good job of balancing between uh the
romance stuff and also with the comedy
and just giving a lot of levity uh
between the dramatic stuff because it
was a very you know difficult situation
that Simon was going through you know he
was just again very also too just
worried about like how how his I mean
because he heard comments you know from
his parent uh was his dad specifically
you know I mean uh making the comment
about I think he said fruity and stuff
like that uh so you know perception is
reality and hold on let me just make
sure
got her y just hit the pause button
there
please on the bottom left there I see it
I see it it's this mouse is like moving
yeah yeah and I
mean
backwards That's goes backwards okay now
continue yeah no and I mean I I
understand again totally why and also
too and in fact by not you know being uh
open about his sexuality like you almost
lost his friends in the process because
yeah he was so scared well not only not
only because so scared but because that
jerk Martin who had a little Redemption
at the end with the ferris well I know I
still didn't like him but a tiny bit of
redemption a tiny tiny bit of redemption
and I did like that one even though it
was cringe I did like that one moment in
the waffle place where he W uh where he
was just saying like you deserve a damn
hero cringe but I did like it uh but um
I just just again I I I did appreciate
the fact that um he he he was afraid to
come out there but again the truth will
usually come out and you know again that
that that sets up for that set up for
you know like what happened with his
friends and you know it he almost lost
them in the process so but I also love
the fact too that that whole thing that
at the end where he inspired people to
not be afraid to show their feelings and
who they are I thought that was
beautifully it's so beautiful and I
thought Greg berlan who I only know as a
producer for the CW verse I thought he
did a hell of a job directing this film
the performance is so so well done so
endearing he killed it yeah really yeah
know it was it was really endearing and
I liked
how it captured
like it was it was a movie that could
talk about in an honest way but also
address those other perspectives on it
you know and like I think the the moment
for me was like seeing when he came out
on Christmas watching his Dad's reaction
versus his mom's reaction and his dad
not knowing how to process it and his
mom seemingly accepting him from the
jump and then I know you got emotional
at both parents part but I think the the
part that really got me uh in tears was
like you've been holding your breath for
years and I was like a man like someone
was just like holding something so tight
that they they can't breathe they can't
um operate in in comfortability because
they have to hold something so near and
dear or something
so oh not even treacherous that's not
the right word but like some something
that's so sensitive and and close to
them and me be able to live in Freedom
like that I think that's very
um yeah it's it's very uh not not
admirable but the fact that his mom was
able to see him and that was beautiful
yeah no those were probably two I mean I
I I love the whole movie but those
scenes were just so I mean just how
accepting his parents were especially
his mom and then his dad it's not that
he wasn't accepting he was just like he
just didn't know how to react in the
moment just because he was expecting his
son to be this raging testosterone man
to get all the women kind of thing so
it's just like and again he was trying
to deal with I think he said it best
like in the moment he was trying to deal
with it best with comedy and like joking
around like deflecting yeah exactly he
was deflecting for sure so uh but like
to come back with him and just say hey
you're still my boy I still love you
like that was just so heartfelt so sweet
I love that and um again there were some
really powerful moments in in this uh
film as well in terms of you know how
the Cobra Kai Chris the guy who looks
like Chris Brown and uh the other bully
how they were treating Simon and then
the other kid uh in school too uh how
awful they were treating and how
insensitive and I love how that one
teacher I think it's the Cabaret teacher
how she just did the mic drop on them
but it's it's just crazy we live in a
time I mean I've never I to to really be
blunt with you guys I actually dealt
with uh being uh I was bullied myself in
Middle School not for the same reason uh
it was not about sexuality just I was
just bullied um so I can understand you
know what Simon was going through again
not for the same reasons just being
bullied it sucks it's not fun at all um
although difference being as I was
physically bullied whereas uh Simon was
being mentally uh bullied but still
either way they both are terrible um but
it's just again just so crazy to me we
live in a society where not all but some
people can get to a point where they
feel that's necessary a lot of times too
that can be a ramification of just the
craziness that's going on in their own
minds and you know what they're dealing
with and then you know they bring it
into the world for um you know because
again what they're you know what's going
on in their lives and I feel bad for
them I really do yeah uh it sucks uh and
I wish them well uh and get the help
that they need um because we should all
be accepting of you know if it it
doesn't affect your life so I don't know
why you have to you know get on other
people for things you know even if you
don't agree it's they they likely like
they feel small at home so they got to
make other people feel small make
themselves so big you know the usual
bully thing yeah and if you don't agree
hey that's your business it's all good
like keep it to yourself no worries like
you don't have to get on someone else
for something you don't agree with
that's that's fine uh all good you know
we're not all going to agree with
everything in this world and you know
that's what makes the world go around
but you don't need to bring someone else
down to uplift yourself is kind of all
I'm saying um God I just want to punch
Martin still um
anyway but hey he he gave a great I
thought that actor like he was so
annoying but he gave a great performance
he did he did his job he made me cringe
he made me mad so I'm like Kudos too you
played that role very well yeah I don't
want to see you I don't want to see that
character in real life but hey yeah
great giv no but hey seriously though
Beautiful film uh and again I really
appreciate it I think his name was Zack
Robinson the main actor who played Simon
great performance fantastic seriously
great I mean it's a very difficult job
to uh be the lead in a film and I
thought and drama yeah he really carried
the film you could see how much weight
like just what he was holding within him
and just like to to still like be such a
a wonderful kind human being and you
know with everything that he was
withholding within himself like I just
really love this character so much and
I'm so glad I I got to uh watch this
film was a really good one and again so
impressed with Greg perlan I didn't even
know he was a director so uh I was
really impressed stick to dramas Greg
yeah stick to stick to stuff like this
you know I mean you had to run in the
superhero world but like you did a good
job into by the way but uh yeah I'm very
impressed with him as a director do you
have any final thoughts you'd like to
say if not did your did your brain also
do that thing like when you're watching
it I was just like what what superhero
would he play what comic book character
would he play are you talking about
Simon yeah oh uh I didn't say that but I
mean I'm usually always saying stuff
like that every time I see like a young
leading actor I'm like what kind
character would you play I know I with
his performance in this film he he could
do any type of I mean he really showed
me a lot of acting range in this film he
was F he was fantastic great Peter
Parker I could see it I was act okay yep
you got me there no when he had his
glass when he had his glasses on at that
dance and the woman and the girl said to
him I love you and he's like and then he
went into the bathroom and told his mom
that uh uh there's drugs or drinks at
the party like come get me or something
actually was thinking Peter Parker no
joke I really was I'm not just agreeing
with you to agree with you I really did
say that in my head you just reminded me
of that I really was thinking that good
call anyways what did you guys think of
the film love Simon um love to hear your
thoughts in the comments section below
are there other films like this or other
films just in general that you would
like Aaron myself other members of the
real rejects to react to we'd love to
hear your thoughts down below and we
wish you all a wonderful New Year and
take
care Tyler he happy New Year buddy now a
friendly reminder to everyone who hasn't
heard this yet Tyler hey he gave us a uh
I gave me not us sucker dead beat yeah
you haven't once touched the
PS5 it's actually a four that he gave me
remember that's right it was a PS4 well
see how much I know I got the PS4 and
then you got so I could play Red Dead
Redemption too now at the beginning of
that time it would became a really
daunting experience and I got
sidetracked beat plenty of other games
on that new system but uh did not be red
dead and then randomly over the holidays
I was like you know what I'm going to
pick up Red Dead too cuz I need a a game
that I could just get lost in the world
for sure and dude I've stuck to it at
least a couple times a week I've been
playing uh after usually really late at
night to wind down the M I got a really
unhealthy habit what I do is I take a
melatonin so I can get tired but if I
just lay there with melatonin I don't
get tired I need to distract my brain so
take a melatonin I play a game stimulate
my mind with these brain waves of truns
and headphones on and then I get tired
and I fall asleep and I have a Restless
sleep and I'm like oh my God I'm all
groggy what the hell but at least I was
asleep but I actually got to bed though
yeah like 3 in the morning get it work
sure so uh yeah man and I'm on i' I've
officially gone way further past where I
last left off years ago so uh because I
started all over again and so man I'm
just going to keep you upd on the
journey it's been a great journey with
it and I hope in 2024 uh the next time
you're out in Cali you best bet I'm
going to make the time to meet up with
you as long as it's not like a half hour
away if you're in like a 20 minute range
we could
that's but if you're more than 30
minutes I don't even know who you are I
don't like do things exist 30 minutes
from here I'm going to forget
about why I care to meet up with you in
that time frame I extra 10 minutes I get
so distracted will be cleared I get so
distracted by the stress of losing that
amount of time cuz time is money man
time is money time is valuable all right
that's why we charge $130 on Cameo
that's
right people get that that's and then we
record like a 40 minute long you know
video and I don't understand why we get
no cameos now you
know people are weak and they $20 to 130
people they just don't think that
they're worthy of such a good came that
was a good gradual build honestly um but
Tyler man
uh what is new's resolution be Tyler's
New Year's resolution should be uh to
line every surface in his house with
screens if anybody could do it because
then you could get into the Guinness
Book of World Records and then you could
pretty much retire off that and also
ride like the notoriety to get you know
like free access to like most things in
life so if you became like the guy with
the most TVs coding every surface in his
home find a couple creative ways to like
you know morph doors and things like you
know that could really be your key to
Mor doors porest Mor doors the porest
floors there a chorus
s over
my I don't know what speaker system
rymes with
bores
bors yeah Mor mors
LS Norse Norse with my my Norse horse
with the force of Norse
horse on the back of a
horse with no remorse no remorse killing
people to the
floors that's an awfully hot coffee
pot oh that's going to be my goal for
2024 Tyler is uh is to get good enough
at Eminem freestyling that I'm always
ready to go 16 bars worth of random
lyrical
Miracle word
salad all righty buddy I guess this was
your shout out love you
[Music]